the way that i determine who to trust is
whether people were skeptical of the
official narrative
um but we're basing that in data so for
example one of the people who i
personally trust again name dr marty
mccary from johns hopkins university
very early on he and i talked pretty
much every week on the show
and very early on he was very skeptical
of the lockdowns uh he he was very
skeptical of the idea that if you're 20
years old you shouldn't be working or
that we should be
not treating people who are 20 uh in a
different way then we're treating people
who are 70 for example
because he was skeptical of that but he
was taking the science pretty seriously
uh i i
had a lot of respect for that same thing
with j batacharya from stanford if you
just bought hook line and sinker the
actual official narrative throughout
and the idea and you never cited the
data if you ever at any point said
the science says then i have pretty much
a problem with you because science is a
process science is not a person or an
institution
and so there's sort of a group of people
who i think were skeptical of some of
the narratives
and and who would do a good job it
seemed we
decided to trust in politics they do a
good job sort of seal manning the other
argument and then say okay and here's
where i think the flaws are and they'd
give a nuanced picture of the data as
opposed to people who are just like
you listen to me and if you don't listen
to me you're an idiot in which case i
think pretty much always you don't
listen to those people
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the founding editor-in-chief of the
daily wire the host
of the ben shapiro show author of the
new book the authoritarian moment how
the left weaponized america's
institutions against dissent
and the fastest talking jew on all of
the internet ben shapiro
welcome back to the reuben report hey
good to talk to you
all right my friend first off i googled
that and it did you did come up as fast
as talking jew
on the internet how do you feel about
that i mean accurate
also i don't know it would be flatter or
insulted but you know it is what it is
life is reality facts don't care about
my feelings it's all right
facts do not care about your feelings
all right so look we're going to get
into the book obviously this is what
your 87th book or
95th or where are we at now yeah
something like that i i can never
remember it's either my 11th or 12th
depending on the case yeah it's a lot of
books as a guy who just finished my
second
i admire someone that has written this
many books um
but let's just start sort of just
generally with what's going on in the
world which will kind of get us to the
book because that's really what this is
all about
uh kovid's little bananas right now now
or at least the reaction
to kovid uh where are you at at this
point
with the whole thing so the pandemic is
over as far as i'm concerned from a
public policy perspective that does not
mean that the pandemic is like
technically over like you can walk
outside without vaccination without mask
everything's fine
but what it does mean is that all public
policy is designed to do is achieve
certain objectives originally
we were told that the public policy with
regard to coveted was designed to
prevent
the overrunning of the hospitals and so
we all locked down and we all messed up
and then we prevented the overrunning of
the hospitals and then the idea was okay
well now we're gonna delay indefinitely
until we can get to the vaccine
and then these miraculous vaccines came
around and the idea was okay the
vaccines are now available and then we
said okay well we'll wait until
every adult has had the chance to either
take it or not take it as the case may
be because they are super duper
effective
and now we've reached that and now the
problem is there's no actual next goal
and this is something that is driving me
up a wall if you listen to
people on cnn or msnbc or in the
administration talk
it seems that the goal is zero covet
like every single person in the united
states getting
getting the vaccine and then kova just
going away and no one actually thinks
this is ever going to happen
this is a disease that has been seeded
over every country pretty much on planet
earth
it's taken a minimum of 4 million lives
probably closer to 6 million if you look
at the actual stats from india
and certainly if you include the actual
number of dead from china a lot more
lives than that
and the the notion that this is just
going to go away if we yell at people to
get the vaccine is crazy which which
means to me that basically
now that every adult has had the
opportunity to take the vaccine
and because thank god this disease is
not really affecting kids in in severe
ways like the total number of kids under
the age of 18 who have died is still
under 350
in a sub-population of 75 million we're
done
i mean as far as public what public
policy can accomplish or should seek to
accomplish
we are pretty much done at this point
and the problem for the left is that
they set as a goal
the idea of zero covered back last year
and now they can't let go of it
so biden is kind of suck between a rock
and a hard place on the one hand he
wants to claricove it over so we can all
go back to work and everybody can enjoy
life and he can say that he beat the
thing
on the other hand he's actually in order
to do that he has to acknowledge
that we have to live with the virus
which would open the can of worms that
last year democrats said we should
certainly not live with the virus and
anybody who said we should live with the
virus like governor desantis in florida
was bad and evil so instead we're going
to get this ridiculous specter of people
trying to scare you
into being okay with giving up liberties
that really at this point there's no
scientific rationale for so you're going
to continue asking your kid
even though again this thing is not
radically damaging to children i mean
810
kids died of pneumonia in the same
period that coveted killed something
like 350 kids over the course of the
last year and a half or so
the the you're supposed to mask up your
kid to protect the 40 year olds who
decided not to get the vaccine
or if you're vaccinated you're supposed
to mask up in case god forbid you give
it to somebody who again
decided not to get the vaccine like that
none of that is good public policy so
i'm
i'm annoyed by it i'm frustrated by it i
also think it's a bad incentive
structure
because i don't know why i who according
to peop
the powers that be did the right thing i
got vaccinated my wife got vaccinated my
parents got vaccinated
why am i supposed to penalize myself by
masking up to protect people who are
overtly
not only not vaccinating but also saying
they don't care whether
i wear a mask or not it's bizarre what
would you say to those people at this
point because there obviously are a lot
of people i think it might be as many as
something like 30 to 40 percent of
american adults that are not vaccinated
that are saying i either had it and i
have the antibodies or i just don't want
this vaccine which basically was
produced in about a year or whatever
reasons that might have what would you
say to those people
at this point so number one you're a
free and independent human being you're
an adult and it's your decision that's
that's number one number two
if we're talking about you already had
covet i i certainly see the rationale
there's some pretty good data suggesting
the natural immunity is as strong if not
stronger
than vaccine immunity what i would say
is that for a lot of people the
given evidence shows depending on your
age and depending on your health factors
that your
rate of death from covid outweighs the
rate of adverse effects
from the vaccine so far as the data that
we have yet seen and this is pretty much
true for everybody above
the age of 18. i i haven't seen the data
between 12 and 18 so much and certainly
for kids
i i have very little interest in
vaccinating my seven five and one year
old
at this point but if you're 35 years old
or 40 years old and you're saying well
you know
i i thought i got i'm hearing a lot of
this i thought i got coveted
but i wasn't actually tested for
covenant i'm sure i had it before well
unless you were tested for it it might
have been something else right there a
lot of other sicknesses going around i
was sick several times during
coveted pandemic never got coveted so
don't rely on that
take into account your own risk factors
and then seriously consider getting the
vaccine because frankly
the risks from the vaccine from what i'm
seeing in the data uh are not
particularly high and the risks from
covid are depending on your age
maybe somewhat higher maybe multiple
times higher um but again i respect your
abilities and individuals choose as long
as you're willing to live with the
consequences if you don't get the
vaccine and then you get sick
you know that would be a you problem
don't come to public policy seeking a
solution
right to that point though how have you
in the last year have you figured out
who you can trust or what institutions
you can trust because it seems to me
we've just seen a complete
collapse across the board political
cultural uh
you know journalistic just the entire
thing has completely collapsed and
that's what people ask me
almost more than anything else at this
point dave who do you trust how do you
figure out how to make some sense of
this
i mean the way that i determine who to
trust is whether people were skeptical
of the official narrative um but we're
basing that in data so for example one
of the people who i personally trust
again name dr marty mccary from johns
hopkins university very early on he and
i
talked pretty much every week on the
show and very early on he was very
skeptical of the lockdowns
he was very skeptical of the idea that
if you're 20 years old you shouldn't be
working or that we should be
not treating people who are 20 uh in a
different way then we're treating people
who are 70 for example
because he was skeptical of that but he
was taking the science pretty seriously
uh i i had a lot of respect for that
same thing with jay bhattacharya from
stanford
if you just bought hook line and sinker
the actual official narrative throughout
and the idea and you never cited the
data if you ever at any point said
the science says then i have pretty much
a problem with you because science is a
process science is not a person
or an institution and so there's sort of
a group of people who i think
were skeptical of some of the narratives
and and who would
do a good job it's simply decided to
trust in politics
they do a good job sort of seal manning
the other argument and then say okay
here's where i think the flaws
are and they'd give a nuanced picture of
the data as opposed to people who are
just like you listen to me and if you
don't listen to me you're an idiot in
which case i think
pretty much always you don't listen to
those people right so this will kind of
segue us to the book but are you
surprised in the last year
i remember like two or three weeks into
covid it was one of the many times in
the past year that ben shapiro has
trended on twitter
because you said the very obvious
statement in essence that we are going
to have to live
with a certain amount of death a certain
amount is
it's just what actuaries have to deal
with when they're figuring out insurance
rates
and that's just the reality of life and
of course everyone in media matters and
all the usual clowns
we're saying that ben shapiro wants to
kill old people and everything else but
are you related to that are you
sort of surprised how quickly everyone
folded and even now
you can sense that there's a certain
amount of people in the media
that want lockdowns again they want more
government programs like they just
they're getting off on this they just
they just like it yeah
i mean i think that that is very true i
think this has become almost a pagan
worship ceremony for a lot of people
um because again i'm i'm not
anti-masking under certain circumstances
i'm not anti-masking for unvaccinated
people who are with other unvaccinated
people who are vulnerable to covet i
mean i i was never
anti-faulty until he started pretty much
overtly lying to us in a wide variety of
cases
i've been pro-vaccine throughout this
entire pandemic so yeah i
find it shocking however the number of
people who are much more interested in
castigating people
who are using their own independent risk
assessment and coming to a different
conclusion
or analyzing the data in a different way
but looking at the data i'm i'm
you know shocked at the number of people
who have decided that they are more
interested in the partisan virtue
signaling than
even examining the data that's the part
that i find really shocking
and the eagerness with which people are
going back to well you're not masking
this is where it's going to go right
they're going to say the cdc will issue
some sort of guidance saying if you're
vaccinated you ought to mask up and i'm
going to say no i've already said no
i vaccinated i am not transmitting the
disease the numbers of people who are
asymptomatically transmitting covid
well vaccinated is very low the number
of breakthrough infections is very very
low according to the new york times 160
million people vaccinated in the united
states
there's been something like 6 000
breakthrough cases i'm not masking up
for that and most of all
it's one thing to make the case that i
should mask up if somebody can get the
disease
through no fault of their own but if
you've had the opportunity to get a
vaccine and then you didn't and then i
give you covet
that one is kind of on you that's really
not on me anymore but there will be this
move like if somebody says that you need
to mask up despite being vaccinated and
you say no
then it will be back to oh you're
willing to kill grandma it's like no i
was never willing to kill grandma
yeah but it's become much more about the
partisan
it's why you see people yelling at
people who are unvaccinated right it's
not because
they actually want to convince those
people to vaccinate if you want to
convince somebody to vaccinate you do
what i said earlier you treat them as an
individual human being
you take a look at the risk factors you
try to analyze those on an individual
level and assuage the fears
if you want to create a sort of
polarized
you're a bad person i'm a good person
thing then when you say you're an idiot
a [ __ ] if you don't vaccinate on my
timeline
as i seek as i see fit and no matter
your prior health scenario
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell